>> Aaron Taub: Okay.
All right, welcome everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
Thank you to our
distinguished guests.
My name is Aaron Taub.
I'm with the Israel and Judaica
section here at the library.
Aaron Taub is my name.
Today's program, Welcome to
Theatreland and, a presentation
by internationally acclaimed
Israeli actor, director
and I've just been told, diva,
Roy Horowitz is sponsored
by the researcher and reference
services division and LC Globe
in cooperation with
the Embassy of Israel
and the Edlavitch DCJCC Gloe, so
thank you to all those partners.
Just two quick announcements,
please silence your cell phones,
you already know that.
Also, this event
is being recorded
to be webcast at a later date.
There is a chance that during
the Q&A, you might be filmed,
so if you don't want
to be, don't step up.
I would like to thank Megan
Metcalf, Chairperson of LC Globe
for arranging this program.
Where's Megan?
In the corner.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you to Oren
Ben-Yosef, Cultural Attache
of the Embassy of Israel.
Carole Zawatsky, Executive
Director of the DCJCC,
our own Gail Shirazi from
the Israel Judaica section
and of course, our
speaker Roy Horowitz.
Roy is generously donating
a variety of materials
from various Israeli
theaters to the library.
This gift will augment
LCs collection
of Israeli theater
posters and DVDs.
These original source
materials are made available
to researchers at LC in our
various divisions, posters
and imprints and
photographs division
and in the Hebraic section, DVDs
and other audio visual materials
in the motion picture and
recorded sound division.
Oren and Roy are
also working together
to help us acquire items that
will enrich our collection
of the LGBT material from Israel
and their many other resources
throughout the library related
to these topics.
In each division, there are
knowledgeable librarians
available to assist
you with your research.
So, without further ado, I
would now like to invite Oren
to the podium to introduce Roy.
[ Applause ]
>> Oren Ben-Yosef: Thank
you very much Aaron.
Good afternoon everybody.
I'm so pleased to
see you all here.
My name is Oren Ben-Yosef
and I'm the Director
of Cultural Affairs
with the Embassy
of Israel to the United States.
On behalf of the embassy, I
would like to thank Meg again
from the Women's
Gender and LBGTQ studies
for your friendship and
collaboration with us
and various cultural programs.
Your creative ideas are
always exciting and leading
to positive change
and innovation
and we are very much
appreciative of that.
I would also like to thank
Aaron, the head of the Israel
and Judaica section at Library
of Congress for your friendship
and for your, for supporting
our cultural programs as well.
I'm honored for the
opportunity to help you carry
out your vision of building
the largest collection
of human knowledge
ever assembled
by donating materials
related for the,
from the Israeli
theater brought to you
by our special guests, Roy.
By having this program today,
I feel that we are a part
of your mission to serve an
accessible and relevant source
of knowledge to the
general public.
And, we look forward of
course, for future joint events
and cooperation between
the Embassy of Israel
and the Library of Congress.
And, now for the star
of the afternoon,
it is my absolute pleasure to
introduce to you Roy Horowitz,
an Israel leading actor,
director, dramaturge
and lecturer for theater and
universities around the world.
Aside of being a good friend,
he is also extremely talented
as you are about to
see in a few minutes.
Roy also teaches
in acting schools
and won distinguished awards
and honor scholarships
for his theatrical work.
In the past, he was a manager
of theater in Israel as well.
Some more fun trivia about Roy.
He is a vegetarian,
he likes dogs
and sometimes he can be a bit
childish which we love the most.
And, most importantly, he's
very, very happy to be here
with you today, so
please welcome the awesome
Roy Horowitz.
[ Applause ]
>> Oren Ben-Yosef: Aaron,
can you please join me.
Yeah, there's a lot of good
stuff from Israeli theaters.
>> Roy Horowitz: I understand
that you only get 12,000
materials everyday so,
I'd like to add some more.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Roy Horowitz:
These are programs
from the latest shows,
productions of --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Aaron Taub: Roy
the stage is yours.
>> Roy Horowitz:
Thank you so much.
>> Aaron Taub: Thank
you very much.
>> Roy Horowitz: Not only
that I'm happy, I'm really,
I'm thrilled, I'm excited, I'm
overwhelmed actually, just,
you know, crossing from
this enormous building
and collections is really
something which is breathtaking,
so I'm honored to be here
and thank you everybody
for having me.
What I'm about to do, actually
it's, it's a mission impossible,
I would like to try and
portray or to say what's there
to be said about the
theatrical scene in Israel
which is really very
intense, very alive
and kicking and very diverse.
And, I would like to shed
some light about what's going
on in the field of theater in
Israel, because I truly believe
that it has a lot to offer
to communities outside Israel
and I'm very happy to actually
to take part in the effort
of trying to portray
a bit or not a bit,
a substantially different
profile of Israel
from what it's usually pictured,
you know, in global media.
I think at least in
the field of theater,
we really are very
original and special
and as I've said,
have a lot to offer.
What I'd like to do, because
we only have some 40 minutes
and then we'll open it
for a Q&A, is that I would
like to combine, you know,
all the different sides
of my schizophrenia.
I would like to be a bit of
an academic at the beginning
and give you some data
and some information
about the theatrical theme.
And, then being mostly an actor,
I brought with me some texts
and I would like to just read
to you and show some clips
which I think will do a better
service to the point I'd
like to expose you to some of
the most important playwrights,
Israeli playwrights nowadays
and to let the work
speak for itself.
Maybe I'll start with just
some general data as I've said,
Israeli, is really
a theatrical empire.
In Tele Aviv alone,
we have every evening,
some 50 different shows
and the venues are packed.
Israelis flock to the venues
and I think it's the 10th
or 11th year in a row that
Israel has the highest rate
of theater goers in
the world per capita.
Please bear in mind that
what keeps the industry going
in places like, yours, Broadway,
New York or the Western London,
not the local people but
mostly the tourists, you know,
that allow mousetrap
[inaudible] to run forever.
In Israel, these are the
Israelis who come and flock
as I said, to the venues
and we have a very intense,
some may say, maybe a bit of
inflation, very intense scene
and it is very diverse
as I've said.
We have shows not only in
Hebrew, but also in Arabic,
Yiddish, in Amharic,
in Russian, in English
and I think it's just a
matter of time until we have,
we'll find that we'll
also add shows in French
with all the French newcomers
to Israel in recent years.
Israel is very unique,
we have some kind
of abnormalities I think or some
very specific characteristics
which I think I'd
like to point out.
First of all, I don't,
to best of my knowledge,
I think Israel is the only
country in the world to have,
for example, it's national
theater established long ago
before the establishment of
the actual state, you know,
our national theater,
Habima which I come from,
was established in 1917
in Moscow, in Russia,
whereas the state of
Israel came to life
in 1948, some 31 years later.
Israel is the only country
in the world to have,
to have its national theater not
functioning in the capital city
of Jerusalem, but in Tel Aviv.
Jerusalem is not yet ready
for the revolution of theater.
And, Israel is, as I've said,
is really in love with theater
and I think this might
be explained by the fact
that theater is relatively a
new phenomena to Jewish culture,
Jewish culture and Jewish
life, whereas the rest
of the Western world have
been experiencing theater ever
since Ancient Greece, you
know, some 2,500 years ago.
Jews started dealing or enjoying
or practicing theater
less than 200 years ago.
We are very new to the business
and I think that in comparison
to ordinations, the fact
that we are very new to it,
maybe explains why we are still
very much in love with it.
Whereas, the rest of the
world, you know, came to terms
with theater, it's one way
among other forms of, you know,
of a day or a night outside.
Israel is very much
celebrating the fact
that we are finally allowed to
enjoy an evening in the theater,
because for many, many,
generations, the orthodox,
Jewish authorities rejected
the sheer concept of theater.
Theater was something which
was identified with then,
with the gentiles something
which is not done, you know.
Jews had been thanking the
Lord for many generations
for making them [inaudible]
yeshivas and synagogues and not
of this [inaudible] of mockers
as they call the theater.
They're not going to theaters
or to circuses, God forbid.
So, and some 150
or 200 years ago,
as part of what we call
the national renaissance,
[inaudible] the national
secular revolution
which took part some 150 years
ago, theater actually managed
to put its foot in the door
and we started practicing
theater as well.
At the beginning, just
for your knowledge,
it was allowed only one
day in the Jewish calendar,
we already have one,
how do you say,
one day which is freaky and, you
know, pulling and they allowed,
if you want to do your shows,
use this day of the year
where we, we get drunk
and we change costumes
and do your shows
during that day,
but you know the slippery slope?
Once it was allowed, it
was inevitable and it ended
up with what I described
at the beginning,
that today you can have
theater performances in Tel Aviv
at 10:00 in the morning, at
noon, at 2:00, at 4 p.m.,
at 6 and at, in the evening,
its' really incredible,
what is going on.
And, the thing diverse
from the national theater
to municipal theater, to
independent groups to children
in youth companies,
to independent artists
to dance theater, you
have the whole range.
One thing, one fact which I
find interesting is that 77,
I checked the numbers, 77% of
the repertoire which we present
in Israeli theater is based on
original, original new writing
where the most of the what
is being produced is Israeli
dramaturgy[DJ1], Israeli plays.
Besides, you know, we do
of course, the classics
and the last musicals, you know,
the most updated
musicals from Broadway.
Everything, there is
a place to, everything
but 77% original writing.
You know, let's just
jump into the water.
I would like to give you some
examples before my time passes.
Now, it's tough choices.
You know, what I
start with him, yeah,
I'll start with Honoch
Levin is the most,
Honoch Levin is the most,
considered to be
the most important,
influential Israeli playwright
ever, he died at the age
of 56 unfortunately at the,
this year we are going to,
it's going to be 20 years
that passed he away.
He died in 1999.
But he left us with an
enormous amount of plays, some,
over 70 plays he managed to
write, not to mention hundreds
of poems, of children's books,
sketches, lots of materials,
all his writings is something
which holds some 17 volumes
in the library and I would
like, and he is considered
and I think rightly
so, one of the most,
even influential playwrights
of the 20th Century,
not just in Israel.
For example, in France
nowadays there are no less
than 6 productions of
his plays running now.
The world actually
begins to know
that there has been a very
good work done in Israel
in translating his
plays in many languages
and there are productions
all over the world actually
and I brought some examples just
to show you what it's,
what it's all about.
I would like to start
from a play
which long ago became some
kind of Israeli classics
by Hoch Levin, named Krum.
And, I would like to read
to you the opening scene.
We have, it's a very
typical Honoch Levin scene.
We have, we meet, we've
have a Jewish mother
and all Jewish mothers tending
in an airport in a terminal,
waiting for her son to
come back from abroad
and she is very excited and she
waits for him and in he comes
and that's the dialogue,
very, prepare yourself
to a very Jewish humor I think.
So, the mother says, oh,
the plane just landed.
In another minute,
I'll see my son.
Oh, here he comes.
The son steps in
and said, and says,
I didn't' make it abroad mother.
I didn't make money
and I didn't get happy.
I didn't have fun, didn't get
ahead, I didn't get married,
didn't get engaged and
I didn't meet anyone.
I didn't buy anything,
didn't bring anything.
All I have in my suitcase is
dirty underwear and toiletries,
that's it, I've told
you everything
and I want you to
leave me alone.
[ Laughter ]
>> Roy Horowitz: Oh, I'm sure
he's planning a surprise for me.
No! No, mother.
Definitely a little
surprise for mom.
No! No! What are
you yelling for?
Someone wants something
from you?
You came back to fight?
They are aggravating me already.
You are lucky I don't
like to yell in airports.
Let's go. They leave and a
day after, I skip a little,
the day after, they
sit in their apartment
and they have lunch together
and he says to her, mother,
I can't stand people looking
at me while I'm eating
and pinning all their
hopes on me.
Whose hoping?
Who even wants anything
from you?
Looking at me and pinning your
hopes on me day and night.
What does he want from my life?
I'm looking at a fly.
In my own house, I'm not
allowed to look at a fly?
The fly is going out
to eat in a restaurant.
Go! Go, into the restaurant, the
meal you start eating as a son,
you'll finish as an orphan.
He walks out and the
neighbor walks in,
the neighbor is the devil of
this play, her name is Felicia
and she comes in and she
says, hi, hello Mrs. Krum,
I just saw your son going
out looking very angry.
No, excited, he's excited
because he came back
from abroad yesterday.
Okay, if you say so.
He didn't bring you anything?
I have everything.
A little TV set.
I have one, yes, made in Israel.
You can see very well on it.
A leather coat, a
wallet, a handkerchief.
Oh, well. Mrs. Felicia, my son
came back from abroad strong
and healthy, that's what counts.
He is healthy, he works
and supports himself.
What else can I ask for?
He even managed to save some of
his salary for a trip to Europe.
We are not arguing about
Europe now Mrs. Krum.
It's true that he
went, even though,
everybody's going these days.
What's the big deal?
A plane takes you, a plane takes
you back, but he went, he went,
the question is, is a person
traveling to achieve something.
Is he even progressing
towards something?
Is he building something?
And especially, is he moving
towards some happy event?
Look, I'm absolutely not
disappointed in my son.
He is talented.
Of course, no need to jump
into disappointment right away.
You can always keep on waiting
and hoping, but the question is,
for how long, a person
doesn't stay 40 forever.
My son's 38!
If you say so.
And for God, there is still
the strength to wait, to hope.
Of course, there is
strength Mrs. Krum,
the question is whether
there is a point.
As long as he's healthy
and feels good.
Healthy and feels good, Mrs.
Krum, everybody's healthy,
the question is, what a
person does with his health.
Does he know how
to take advantage
of the time he's healthy?
Does he have something in hand
to justify his healthiness
and second of all, who
can say I'm healthy?
I'm mean sickness is
always laughing at us.
Pardon, I have no complaints.
To each his own.
One person becomes a doctor and
another becomes a decorator.
The main thing is that you
are happy, and she leaves.
The mother stays
alone and summarizes.
Another attack fended off.
My whole life fended off.
My whole life is spent
fending off attacks.
[inaudible] attacking
you from the front,
poverty is already
attacking from behind.
Did you fend off
the attack for rent.
municipal are attacking
from the side.
Did you fend off
municipal taxes?
Felicia is waiting for you.
Did you fend them all off?
Go to bed and fend off
a long empty night.
This is --
[ Applause ]
>> Roy Horowitz: Thank
you, I just love it.
And, I mentioned some short
sketches, not only 70 plays,
but also some very witty
sketches I brought two
short examples.
Let's see what you say
about this one for example.
We are addressing an offstage
dressing room of a magician
who just finished his gig now,
and there is a knock on the door
and there is a man
coming in and he
and the dialogue goes like this.
[ Knocking ]
>> Roy Horowitz: Excuse me.
Excuse me, Mr. Magician,
Mr. Magician,
please could you excuse?
Can't you see I'm busy?
Oh, sorry, sorry.
But excuse me, Mr.
Magician, excuse me for.
What's this about?!
It's just about my wife.
Pardon? My wife.
Ten minutes ago, you were so
kind as to saw my wife in two.
Yes? Are you waiting
for something sir?
No, but my wife.
Yes? You sawed her in two.
Yes, you said so.
Well, and she's still sawn.
Yes, and what's this about?
Well, I wanted to ask, I
don't presume to know anything
about magic, but when are you
sticking her back together?
Pardon? I mean, when are
you sticking the two parts
of my wife back together?
I'm not sticking anything sir.
This isn't a weld shop.
Sorry, sorry.
You're welcome.
But. Yes? My wife, she's in two
pieces and you need to stick,
sorry, to put her back together
like she was before, sir,
you remember don't you?
She volunteered 10 minutes
ago for you to saw her,
you sawed her and
now we are waiting
for you to show us the trick.
Trick?! There are no
tricks with me sir.
I'm a magician.
All right, and my wife.
What about her?
She's sawn, she can't leave like
this when she's sawn in two.
So, why don't you take
her to the emergency room?
Based on your description I
understand that she is in need
of some medical attention.
What, what, what, what,
but the trick, the trick!
You are starting
with the trick again.
I tried politely and guess
what a pain in the ass.
You stick my wife back
together right now!
Firstly, don't shout at me,
because if you're annoying me,
I can turn you into a rabbit
and secondly, with regards
to your wife, if she
really is sawn in two,
then she's probably dead,
there's no surprises here.
Dead?! She's sawn
in two isn't she?
But you are a magician!
What's that got to
do with anything?
I can also saw my wife in two.
No need to.
I've already done it.
This is the black
humor of Honoch Levin.
Lots of his plays and
sketches have been translated
into English and you can
easily find them out.
I would like to go
to another example.
Actually, you know, if I have
to point out, I think I did it,
yesterday I gave another lecture
somewhere else and I was asked
about the most characteristic
thing which I can define
to Israeli dramaturgy and I said
it, I think it's the ability
or skill to inject humor even
into the most heavy
subject matters.
I think we have this incredible
ability of, maybe it's some kind
of survival mechanism, I don't
know psychologically what,
to deal with even the
heaviest stuff with some humor.
And, I think this is a very
good example [inaudible] is the
representative of I think
the younger generation,
the next one to Honoch Levin.
And, I would like to read to
you a scene from her first play,
she wrote several plays to
this day which is called,
"The Guide to the Good Life".
And, I think this example
will serve me for two things,
one is to show you that
it's a combination of humor
and serious matters and
the other one is you know,
Israeli theater has two
central preoccupations,
one is the Holocaust which
we might come back later on
and the other one is of course
the current events, you know,
in the political situation and
the neighborhood we live in.
And, what she does here is
that I think she manages
to show us what is
living in Israel nowadays,
especially for young people.
The scene I'm about to read
is the character is a woman
in her 30s, she's a single lady
in her 30s longing
to get married.
Her name is [inaudible]
and it starts
with her calling this company,
I'm sure you have it here too,
these coupons or Groupons,
this special offer companies.
She calls them, she saw
an ad and she calls them
and it goes like this.
>> What's the name of the play?
>> The Guide to the Good
Life by [inaudible].
It was a major hit in Israel.
Hello? Beauty Bargain?
Hi, yes I'd like
some information.
The slimming soap
that liquidizes body
fat, is it painful?
Okay. And, the body fat
that melts away, what,
does it just wash
off in the bathroom?
Great! I'd like to order
one of those please, yeah.
Oh, one more thing, the
electronic breast muscle shaper,
it doesn't actually
electrify your boobs does it?
How do you attach
it to your breasts?
Oh, vacuum?
Lifting and refirming and
does it enlarge them as well?
Oh, that's what the
natural capsules are for?
Oh, yes, could you put
them on the list please?
And, they don't give
you cancer do they?
Tested on what, ferrets,
otters, what's a ferret?
A rodent. Oh, ferrets,
they're called ferrets.
Yeah, they're very smelly.
What do I get with it?
An, electrical vibrating bell
for shaping the abdominal
muscles?
For how much extra?
Oh, undetectable under
any item of clothing?
Yes, that's fab.
One less thing, those wonder
drops, Viva Young and Viva Lady,
how can using them
create perfect harmony
with your partner
and significantly improve
your quality of life?
Oh, the libido, whoa.
And, a youthful energy?
Yeah, that's lovely youthful.
Yeah. Yeah, that's
really amazing.
Yes, I'd like the ladies and
the men's too, just in case.
Hold on a second, don't
add this all up yet.
The lifting cream for the
forehead, how high does it lift?
Oh, what a brilliant idea.
All right, all right,
put it on my list.
Yeah, yeah, and total it all up.
I see, I see, can I
pay in installments?
Okay, I'll pay in
18 installments.
Yeah, that way I'll
hardly notice it.
Gosh, what a wonderful deal.
A beauty bargain
indeed, thank you.
A few days later, it's
the middle of the night,
she knocks hysterically
on a friend's front door
and says to her, hi!
Thank you, I don't know what
I would've done without you.
I had no one to call.
My mom would kill me if
she knew I got arrested.
You are an angel.
All right, all right,
[inaudible]
and tell me slowly
what happened.
How come you were
at the policemen
and why the hell
were you detained
as a dangerous terrorist.
Because they thought I
was a suicide bomber.
What?! I bought this electric
vibrating belt for slimming
and shaping the abdomen.
You can wear it under any
piece of clothing and it's,
it's completely undetectable.
I have it on at home,
at work, wherever.
I had a date in the grill bar,
the guy was inside already.
I was about to go in when this
security man shouted at me,
hold it ma'am, stop right there.
What's that under your shirt?
And, I said, nothing, you know,
because it's none
of his business.
You know, it's really
none of his business
and then I keep walking and so
then he jumps me, he pushes me
to the floor and starts yelling,
a suicide bomber,
a suicide bomber!
He tried to rip my shirt off.
Pervert! So, I bit him and
then, then he handcuffed me
and started shouting
at me in Arabic.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Roy Horowitz: And, then the
police came and shoved me away
in case there were
anymore bombs around.
Can I stay at your
house tonight?
Please? Living in
Israel nowadays.
You can't even wear this belt.
Maybe we'll go the next,
you know what, maybe a clip,
not just my own presentations.
This is a clip of, a short clip
of a very witty comedy written
by another playwright,
named [inaudible].
Actually, I understood that
just recently a week ago,
there was a production of, "Oh
God" by her which just closed
in the Mosaic theater here.
She is considered to be one
of the really very
talented, we lost her too.
I don't know what it is
with Israeli playwrights,
she too died of cancer
at the age of 59.
But she left us with
some very rich comedies
and I was very happy to hear
that the Oh God did well here.
This is a comedy which is
called, House Husband I think.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Roy Horowitz: In
Hebrew, house husband,
how would you translate
it, I think, stay at home.
It's about an ex, about a
pilot in the Israeli Airforce
who just retired, you know, they
retire pretty early in their 40s
and is coming back to his
family which the family members,
his wife and his daughters are
not used to having that at home.
And, having him at home now
after he retired makes things
not easy or not simple for them.
And, she wrote a very witty
comedy once again another huge
success at the Comedy Theater in
Tel Aviv and a have a short clip
of it with English
subtitles luckily enough,
so you can see it.
Are we good the lights
and everything,
it's, maybe we should.
Here, it speaks for itself.
But what's with the sound?
Oh.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Roy Horowitz:
Okay, that's it.
Yeah, I think her plays
[inaudible] comedies can
translate very easily and I
could tell from your reaction.
She has another one, by the
way, called, "Family Business",
about once again we come
back to the Jewish mother,
the Jewish mother who refuses to
accept her daughter's plan not
to attend the, the [inaudible],
the past of her eve meal
and she attends to go abroad
with some of her friends
and her mother refuses.
There's no such thing as not
attending the annual setter
and says, over my dead body.
And, literally she
keeps her word in order
to prevent her from growing.
So, this is a [inaudible].
I think mentioned before that
we are very new to the business
and you know, something which
is I find interesting is
that you know, unlike
the enormous contribution
of Jewish artists to the fields
of music or of literature
where you cannot imagine, you
know, the history of literature
without a Jewish
contribution to it.
In the field of drama, all the
great masters are not Jewish.
I think if I'm to think
of a Jewish great master,
I think that maybe the
first name that pops
into mind is maybe
[inaudible] but then we speak
about the mid of
the 20th Century.
Jews haven't been practicing
theater and we are very new
and we do our first steps
and I think it calls for lots
of originality I
think in doing it.
As I said, before, there are
two central preoccupations
for Israeli theater.
One is as I've said, political
issues as we have lots
of political writing going on.
Some of them, of these plays,
I understood yesterday even came
here, arrived to Washington,
made all kinds of
debates here too
when they were performed
here, but there is a lot
of political writing going on.
And, the other one as
I said, the Holocaust.
I think the Holocaust maybe,
it's a bazaar term to use,
but I think it's the
most popular topic
or historical event
over 100 Israeli plays
which can be characterized
as Holocaust plays.
I think that maybe the most
well-known, famous one is,
"Ghetto", Joshua Sobol which
won many prizes and got some,
over 70 productions
all over the world.
But there are many, many, many
productions which deal with,
you know, first generation,
second generation,
third generation.
Also, lots of them has these,
as I've said, this ability
to try pretty much
like you remember,
maybe the controversial female
film from a couple of years ago,
"Life is Beautiful", by Roberta
Benigni which allowed itself
to combine some kind of
comedy with the tragedy,
that tragedy of the Holocaust.
We have lots of plays which
go the same direction.
I see that we are running
out of time and I was asked
to allow you for some Q&A.
And, actually theater for me is,
is always about the dialogue,
so let's open it and
please don't leave me alone.
Yeah, please.
>> You mentioned that the Jewish
theater is relatively new,
but there's a tradition
of Yiddish theater?
>> Roy Horowitz: That's right.
>> You say that the modern
Jewish theater is totally
unrelated to the tradition.
>> Roy Horowitz: No,
I'm not saying that,
I'm saying that the Jewish
theater, with all due respect
to the Yiddish theater, it's a
matter of just 150 years ago.
All these [inaudible]
they are all very new
relatively speaking.
We are speaking about theater
which started, you know,
Goldfaden established
his, which is considered
to be the godfather of Jewish
theater, he started his company
in 1876, so we are very.
This is [inaudible].
This is considered, so we are
only speaking about the history
of Jewish theater in
Yiddish ever since then.
The great miracle of Habima one
of the historical achievements
of Habima for instance, when
it was established in 1917,
it was the first Jewish
theater to do theater for,
by Jewish people, for
Jewish people in Hebrew.
You know, the holy language.
Up to this point it was
only done in Yiddish.
But the whole history is
something of 150-200 years ago.
That's the whole legacy
of Jewish theater
you know in Yiddish.
I know that at a certain
point, you know, in 2nd Avenue
in New York, there
was some over,
I think 100 Yiddish theaters,
you know, and there was
such a prosperity
between the two World Wars
of Jewish theater in the states.
But it's, all in all, it's
a very new phenomenon.
Yes, please.
>> On, the same thing of,
Yiddish tradition, Yiddish humor
and theater, I think
that actually explains
the Israeli love
for theater currently
because it's irreverent.
It's Israeli's love up close
and personal interaction
and irreverent and it's
all comes together.
>> Roy Horowitz:
I totally agree.
You're very much right.
Yes, please.
>> I kind of disagree
with you about.
>> Roy Horowitz:
Agree or disagree?
>> Disagree.
>> Roy Horowitz:
Disagree with me?
How could you disagree with me?
Although what?
>> About major American
contributions
to theater pushed American
Jews invented the musical.
>> Roy Horowitz: The
musical, yes, yes, but.
>> This is theater too.
>> Roy Horowitz: Yes, what
I was talking is the field
of drama maybe.
You know, if you talk about
the graced masters of drama,
you refer to Shakespeare.
[ Inaudible ]
You don't find Jewish
playwrights all for the history,
you know, ever since
Ancient Greece,
that's what I referred to.
Of course, you know,
musical which is an artform
of the 20th Century, of course,
you can't imagine
[inaudible] sure, sure,
so we agree, we don't disagree.
Yes, please.
>> You referenced
a couple of times,
as a catchall phrase,
political theater.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Arrived in Washington
at Mosaic.
>> Roy Horowitz: In
theater [inaudible]
in the beginning, yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Roy Horowitz: Yeah, no,
you see I'm into the
business, I know everything.
Yeah, okay.
[ Inaudible ]
>> If one way of
looking at it a theater
in Israel pre-state is 100
years of political theater,
no question about it
where nothing was immune
from theatrical [inaudible].
My sense is, the past
two decades at least,
political theater in
Israel has been [inaudible],
political climate, government.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Political theater
has been on a decline.
In fact, on the mainstream
companies it's dead indeed,
the fact that we had a number
of plays [inaudible] coming here
to Washington that came here,
it couldn't be produced
in this room.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Related to a point
I think you said
that at the very
beginning, you said,
77% of productions are home
grown [inaudible] place.
I don't want to play the numbers
game, but I looked at the kind
of programs, the program of the
comedy and I saw to my horror,
exactly one Israeli,
one new Israeli play.
It's all musicals great stuff,
adaptations, translations,
Shakespeare [inaudible]
terrific stuff,
but other than in the
fringe, occasionally
in the comments not easy
to find, new Israeli plays.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Roy Horowitz: My observation
with, my observation is that,
thank you first of all,
but my observation is
we totally disagree.
I disagree with you.
First of all, I don't know
which program you saw
of the [inaudible].
I come from the [inaudible] just
directly [inaudible] They do
more than one original play.
It's true that they are doing
all kinds of musicals too
in the big venues but
they produced at least,
at least 4-5 Israeli
original plays every season,
so I can't give you the names.
Otherwise, I don't know which
documentary you referred to.
As for [inaudible]
and the fact that some
of this plays were produced
here even before having
or facing some difficulties in
getting a production in Israel,
I don't really want to get into
but I would say very, you know,
with all, with all due respect
and how do you say, [inaudible]?
>> Cautious.
>> Roy Horowitz: Cautious,
thank you, that I'm not sure
that every play that
wasn't produced it's only
because of its political
content.
I think there are some of
the considerations, you know,
and calculations that
theater directors
and managers do are
sometimes has to do something
with artistic merits you know.
And, I'm not that sure that all
of the plays that were denied
in Israel are really
masterpieces.
>> An example, as a
general observation.
>> Roy Horowitz: You are
right, you are right in the,
you mentioned the name of our
current minister of culture
and once again without going
into, you know, not stepping
into any mine here, you arrived
that there is maybe some decline
in the last year or two, people
are more cautious because,
you know, you know, unlike the
system here, most of the theater
which deals with private
money, most of the theater
in Israel is subsidized
either by the government
or by the municipalities, so
it's, and it calls for some,
you know, it's complicated.
And, I think you are right
with some observations regarding
this [inaudible] period
which might, she came
into clashes with artists
and maybe some of
them got frightened,
but the situation is far from
there is not real censorship.
And, I'm not familiar with any,
you know, good writing, good,
well-deserved, you know,
well-made play which was denied
or someone would
turn down because
of a fear of political content.
I'm not aware of such cases.
Yes.
>> Since LC Globe is one of
the cosponsors of this event,
can you talk about
specifically gay themed plays
that have been produced.
>> Roy Horowitz: Yeah,
there is a first of all
at any given time I think you
can find at least 1 or 2 plays
which has some relevance
to LBGTQ issues.
There is a small French theater
which works at a gay center
in Tel Aviv and specializes
in gay themed plays.
Right now, they are putting,
I think for the fourth time,
Angels in American, a
new production which is
about to open once again.
There is a thing, you know,
in Tel Aviv, it's some kind
of a gay capital as we all know.
We are about to host a
Eurovision as you may know,
the Eurovision Song
Contest this coming May.
In Tel Aviv is really some
kind of a gay, gay paradise.
Certainly, you know,
in comparison
with rest of our neighbors.
So, there is, there is
constant activity, you know,
in this, in this world.
And, even in the repertoire,
in the established theaters,
you know, they do from time to
time, I myself directed a play
which is called, "Volunteer
Man", by an American playwright,
very talented American
playwright.
He got an ABBY award for this
play and named Dan Clancy,
I directed four of his play by
now in Israel and it was done
in our repertoire of theater
and it tells the story
of a volunteer man, a
gay man who is coming
to assist a dying patient in
a hospital and actually deals
with the questions of amnesia
and ending of your life
and it's an encounter between a,
very you know, drugged addict,
very homophobic man and this
feminine, very sensitive teacher
of gay theater come
to assist him.
So, there is, and
as I've said before,
anytime you can find
open productions
which has disappeared anytime.
>> What's the name of
the theater, the gay.
>> They are called,
I don't know how
to translate it into English.
Tahel [assumed spelling],
Tahel stands for --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Roy Horowitz: It's
a homo-lesbian theater,
but in Hebrew is shrines a bit.
Yes?
>> I wanted to ask you about, in
Israel, are there other theaters
that are done in Russian,
English, in Arabic in part
and I want to know about that.
And, you've mentioned just now
the government subsidy issue
and that man in the back grabs,
obliquely referenced shame
which is not Weisman's workshop
playing in Mosaic now where the,
apparently the, the
Jewish Arab theater
in [inaudible] is
closed or something.
And, I know the Kennedy Center
brought a Palestinian play
from a company in Jerusalem.
I just would like you to talk
about that and I mean the state
of different, different ethnic
group theaters and the issue
of the need for government
subsidies
and if the government subsidies
is shutdown then the theater is
shuts down.
>> Roy Horowitz: Once again,
the story we have done due
to the best of my knowledge
is not, they didn't shutdown
because of their
theatrical activity,
but because there was some
issues as with, with some events
that took place within the
facilities of the theater
which are something
against the Israeli law
or of encouraging some kind of
terrorists groups or something.
I don't want to really go
into it because I'm not that,
an expert, but it hasn't
got to do with anything
with their repertoire which was,
there is not real censorship
on which plays you perform.
There isn't and there
was by the way in Israel,
censorship, up to 1988.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Roy Horowitz: Whom I've
mentioned before has some
clashes with the censorship back
then in the 70s and insisted
in performing some of
his satirical plays
without permission and that
was a big deal back then,
but ever since 1988,
it was cancelled,
this comedy of censorship.
What I can say is there are
companies which specializes
in productions, in as I've
said, in [inaudible] there are
at least two subsidized Arabic
theaters besides the [inaudible]
which is about to close.
There is the Gesher
theater which some materials
like I've brought here which
functions, is bilingual theater.
It was established some
25 years ago by new,
by Jewish immigrants
from Russia.
They came as a company pretty
much like Habima back then.
They came and they performed
in both Russian and Hebrew.
They started performing
in Hebrew while they still
didn't know the language
and they had to write a text
in Hebrew, in foreign letters
and so they function regularly.
There is, and there is,
you know, in recent years,
there is a very large population
coming from South Africa
in the city of Ra'anana and they
established their own English
speaking theater which is now
started to be, you have to prove
that you function on your
own for two years in order
to start getting some
subsidy from the government
and they just now
joined the this list
and they will be started,
starting to be supported
as well.
So, there is, a very,
I'm not that of an expert
because I focus mainly on
the Hebrew speaking theater
but I'm quite aware of the fact
that it is being
supported as well.
>> To follow up in the
occupied territories,
is there Hebrew theater,
is there.
>> Roy Horowitz: I
don't believe so.
I don't believe there are.
>> None of the settlements.
>> Roy Horowitz: I
don't, I don't believe so,
but because of some, if I
spoke about history and I spoke
about the love hate relationship
with the Jewish tradition
and the making of theater,
I think there is a large
population, a large population
of the settlers are coming for
more religious, part, you know,
groups of Israeli
society and I am not aware
of any established theater
or company which functions.
Israeli theater,
the Cameri, Habima,
they come and perform there.
They have, you know,
they host productions
from Israeli theater, but
I'm not aware of any theater
which is based there
and produces its own
stuff, not to this day.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Roy Horowitz: Ah, in
Yiddish, yeah I have.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Roy Horowitz: It's
done every decade.
You have at least
one production of,
we can't go without
Fiddler on the Roof.
Tradition, tradition.
>> Are we all set?
Okay.
>> Roy Horowitz: I think so,
thank you, thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
[DJ1]